[Music]
So, as you come in,
we have here a server set up with
everything you'll need. If you want to
follow along, you should have gotten a
post-it note. If you don't, just raise
your hand and my colleague Alex over
here will come find you and we'll
provide you with one. Uh, basically what
you're going to do is you're just going
to go, if you have a number 160 or
below, you go to this link here, the QR
code on top as well. Um, and if you have
a number that's 2011 or above, you go to
the second link or the QR code. From
there, I'll give you some directions.
You're going to have to clone a repo.
Um, and then you're just going to have
to move an environments file over really
quick. Also, for everything in this
deck, I did create a workshop graph
intro slack channel. So, if you're part
of the AIE uh Slack group, you can also
go there and just grab this deck um and
you know, get the links or however
however you'd like to do that. So, we'll
get started here, I think, in just a
couple of minutes. All right. So, your
sorry your your number will give you
your username and your password.
Basically, it's attendee all lowercase
than your number. That'll be both your
username and your password when you sign
in.
The other link that you should try to
open as well is the um browser preview,
but I'll walk you through that here in a
second. I'll give it just another minute
here for everyone to to file in and get
situated.
What is the username and password? The
username and password is going to be
attendee all lowercase and then the
number that you have both the username
and the password are the same.
Question if these are going to be live
um after the session the notebooks. So
the notebooks uh the servers will be
down um after the session but you have
the GitHub link you can go back to um so
the code is is there for you to use um
it's just that the environment won't be
available afterward.
All righty. So I'm going to go ahead and
get started here. I'll leave this screen
for a second. So if you want to grab the
QR codes here, now would be the time to
do it. Um, obviously you can go to the
Slack channel and also pick up this
deck.
All righty.
So,
we're going to do an intro to graph
workshop today. Um, I was debating what
to actually put in this workshop since
everything's changing so quickly. Um,
and some of my colleagues convinced me
not to make it too complicated. So this
course is going to be very much an
introductory level course. Um if you
want to look at sort of more advanced
graph techniques, integrations with
things like MCP, we have that at our
booth. Um and we have some other things
that we're doing other events um
tomorrow that will go over some of that
stuff and I'll have links to all of that
uh as we go through. But basically what
we're going to do is we're going to get
everything set up. Hopefully that should
only take a few more minutes. And then
we have three modules. We're going to go
over some graph basics. We'll be using
Neo forj today. It's a graph database.
Just how to query that kind of how to,
you know, construct um your logic to
retrieve data. We'll go over um another
module on unstructured data um and how
to do entity extraction.
How many people know about Neo forj?
All righty. How many people have by the
way used Neo forj like have written
cipher queries.
Okay. So some folks in here. And then
how how many people have used lane chain
before?
Okay. So so a fair number of you. Okay.
That's good to know. Um and then in our
in our third module we'll actually go
over we'll use lane graph. We'll build a
very simple agent that will use some
retrieval tools and you'll get to see
how some of that works and we'll wrap up
after that with some resources. So, make
sure to ask questions straight away.
Raise your hand. I'll stop
intermittently. Um, we only have 80
minutes though, so I want to make sure
if you do have a question um go ahead
and raise it and we'll get that answered
because we're going to be moving through
the material um a little bit quickly.
Um, as I said before, we have two
Jupiter servers set up. So, you don't
need to pip install anything. Um, you
can go ahead and connect to these
notebooks. Attendees, I already
explained, you should have a number. If
you don't, go ahead and raise your hand.
Um, the username and password is just
going to be attendee followed by your
number. 160 and less, you go to that
first link. 2011 and larger, you go to
the second link. Um, there's also I if
you can go ahead and open
browser.ne.iopreview.
Um, I'll show you in a little bit.
You're going to log into that as well.
that will let you visualize the graph a
little bit better as we start putting
data inside of it.
Yes.
All right. So, Alex, um, we can get a
number over here.
All righty.
Once you're inside of your environment,
what I want you to do is these two
commands. So, you're going to open up a
terminal window in Jupiter. You can do
that by pressing the little plus sign. I
want you to get clone. The command
should actually be in the read me. It
should say get clone and it will give
you the link to the repository that you
need to clone. And once you do that, I
want you to copy the workshop file over
into that Genai Workshop talent folder.
That environment file WS.N
is going to have information to a
database that's already set up. It will
also have an open AI key inside of it
that we'll be able to use for the
workshop.
So, just to show you what this looks
like,
um,
if I go over here and I look at my my
terminal, right, I've already done this,
this a little bit bigger. You just go
ahead and get clone.
Um, if you go to the readme that was um
in the main folder, this readme here, it
has the uh the um the GitHub URL. So,
you just basically go get clone. Um, and
then oops. And then after that, you just
copy that workshop file into that GEI
workshop talent directory. So, you'll
get this GNAI workshop talent. It's like
a subdirectory in here and you just have
to copy that file and that will have um
resources that you'll need to log into
uh the browser and for you to connect
through your notebooks. The other link
um that is inside of that deck is this
browser.ne.preview
link. Um basically that will give you a
way to visualize the graph. So what you
will do if I go ahead and disconnect
um and maybe I
um go to connect to an instance. So you
should get a screen that looks like
this. And then that workshop file will
have and it should actually be the same
thing for you guys. It should be the
attendee, the number and then the same
thing for the password. So go ahead and
make sure you do that because then
you'll be able to visualize the graph a
little bit better.
Any questions so far?
So for the Jupiter environment, if you
got your number, it's attendee all
lowercase
and then your number for both the
username and the password.
Sorry, where's the connection?
Um,
yeah, ws.m for the for the Neo Forj
browser.
So, it's um right here.
So, it's basically going to be your
username or sorry, it's going to be the
attendee all lowercase and then the
number that you receive for both the
username and the password.
Yeah. And if if you um want to come back
to this if you have if you're connected
through Slack the workshop graph intro,
you can go there and you can pick up the
slides as we move on. So then that way
you just have a constant reference back
to it.
Um so while everyone gets set up here
I'll talk a little bit about just what
graph rag is in general to kind of
motivate what we're doing here. So this
is um an architecture actually um that
represents what some of our customers
do. It's a very common um architecture
for graph rag users. It's generalized
and basically the idea is that you have
your agent over there. You have your AI
models and your your UI. So like all the
normal things that you might think of if
you're putting together a knowledge
assistant. Um but then there's this
knowledge graph thing in the middle. And
that knowledge graph thing you can
ingest both unstructured and structured
data into that. So unstructured being
things like documents and PDFs and that
sort of stuff. And then structured being
tables like CSVs or stuff from a
relational database or what have you.
Um, and so there's a big question of
like, well, why in, you know, the heck
do we need this like knowledge graph
thing in the middle, right? Like we have
agents, we can have tools, and we can go
pick stuff from data sources. Um, and so
the idea with this is that if you have a
use case and you kind of know the types
of questions that you want to answer
with your Asians, by taking your data
and decomposing even a very simple
knowledge graph to start, um, you're
going to be able to expose
um, a lot of the sort of domain logic
that you'd want to apply through the
model of your data. Um, so the idea is
like we'll see when we build a skills
graph, we'll make some relationships
about people knowing skills. And by
making that schema available to the
agent and making tools available to the
agent, um, you're going to be able to
have a lot more control over how data is
retrieved more accurately, explain the
retrieval logic better. Um, and we see
this is especially important as we start
moving more and more into this agentic
world because it's not like a oneshot
vector search anymore, right? We're
starting to see that now when we get
questions or prompts handed to um an
agentic workflow, those start to get
broken down in various ways. Um and when
you have a knowledge graph, it just lets
you um offer retrieval logic to
complement that in in a in a much more
uh simple and and in my opinion a better
manner.
And today we're going to be looking at a
skills and employee graph. Uh so
basically what we'll the use case we'll
be looking at is you're building a
knowledge assistant to help with things
like searching for talent, aligning and
analyzing skills within an organization
um and doing things like staffing and
team formation and substitutions and
things of that nature.
And so I'm going to present a little bit
about what we're going to go through in
these modules first. So I'll do some
stuff inside of a deck. Hopefully it
won't take too long. I just want to kind
of talk to you about cipher and some of
the things that you'll be seeing and
then we'll go ahead and get hands-on
here pretty quickly.
Um, so we're going to talk about
creating a graph. We'll start with some
structured data here just to keep things
simple. I'll introduce unstructured data
a little bit later. Some basic cipher
queries, some algorithms, and we'll get
into some vector search and semantic
stuff.
Um so a knowledge graph basically um
when we think about it a knowledge graph
generally is divi is defined as some as
design patterns to organize and access
interrelated data and at neo forj we
model the data inside of the database is
what's called a property graph and this
consists of three primary elements so
the first are nodes these are like your
nouns these are your people places and
things
next are your relationships these are
how things are related together, hence
the name. Um, and often will be like
verbs. So, person knows person, person
lives with person, person drives or owns
a car. And both of the um nodes and
relationships can have properties which
are just attributes. They can be
strings, they can be numbers, they can
be arrays of things and they can be
vectors as well. So, we can store
vectors for we've had for a long time
inside of Neo forj. um and you can do
search over these things. Now the uh
query language that we're going to use
to access the database is called cipher
and I know a lot of you raised your
hands in the beginning so you already
have some familiarity with this. Um but
cipher kind of looks like asy text. So
the idea right is that um it has this
SQL S kind of feel to it but you get to
write these statements like if you see
match person knows skill um basically
you're connecting a person node to a
skills node through that nose
relationship. So it reads kind of very
um literally in the way that it's
written. Um nodes have what's called
labels uh which is sort of like it would
be the equivalent of a type of table
within a SQL database of basically what
type of entity it is. Um and then as I
said before they have property. So for
example you can identify by a property
like name. Um and you can have variables
like P and S which refer to the actual
um entity as you start to write your
query more. So, this is not going to be
a course on writing cipher, right?
Because we can make an 80-minute course
just on like how are we going to make
cipher queries. Um, but we will be
walking through these queries. So, don't
expect to like be if you haven't seen
Cipher before to be a super expert in
the cipher query language when we're
done. Um, but just know that this is
kind of how it works. And then as you go
through hopefully you'll get a better
understanding and a feel for how these
queries uh work and and the types of
data that can be returned as you run
them.
Um, and so I'm sure is everyone pretty
familiar with vector search in here at
this point? Yeah, I have a feeling this
audience probably would be. So I won't
spend too long on this, right? I think
we all kind of know what embeddings are.
It's basically a type of data
compression. You can apply them to all
sorts of things, right? Text, audio, you
can even apply them to graphs. Um,
oftent times it's just going to be a
vector of numbers and then you can use
that to find similar things within that
domain space. So find texts that are
similar uh semantically not just lex
lexally like actually based on um the
types of things that they're talking
about. Um and within Neo forj you have
search indices including vector. So
there's range indices you have
uniqueness constraints you're able to
search text you're able to do full text
with lucine. Um and then we also have
approximate nearest neighbor vector
search as well that we'll be leveraging
um as we go through in combination with
the cipher queries that we were just
looking at to do graph traversals.
Um the next thing to know about is that
in addition to being able to query the
database, we also have analytics. So we
have graph analytics powered on the
database that lets you do different
types of data enrichment um and do more
graph global type of analytics. So
finding which nodes are most central
according to different algorithms, doing
things like community detection, how do
you cluster the graph, finding paths
between nodes, doing different types of
embeddings. Um so we have a lot of those
algorithms and we'll be touching on them
very very briefly today in the first
module just to show that you know once
you have a knowledge graph you can start
enriching that data and then actually
using things like we'll see in our case
we'll be using community detection um
where we'll be summarizing skills inside
of our graph and then we'll be able to
pass that on to an agent to actually use
that to explain um some parts of our
graph uh for our use case.
All righty. So, with that in mind, we'll
go ahead here and jump into the first
notebook. Um, are there any questions
before we dive in?
Is anyone still Okay. Yes. Over here.
Um, yes. Do you have uh Let me just go
back here
to the
So, and this is available in the Slack
channel, too. If you don't have a
number, um, my colleague Alex over there
can go ahead and grab one for you. Um,
we're in the workshop graph intro Slack
channel, so you can go there to grab the
deck and all the links. But basically,
if your number is 160 or below, you go
to that first Jupiter server. If it's
2011 um or above, you go to the second
one. Um you use attendee all lowercase
and then your number as both your
username and your password. You'll do
that for the Jupiter notebook and then
also for the Neo Forj browser if you
want to follow along with visualizing um
the graph as we go through.
Any other Yes, I know this is
introduction to
um
maybe know when you're building
I see you
smalliz.
So your question is about data modeling
and whether how do you prioritize making
one graph versus multiple graphs. Um I
mean it's a good question. I think in
general for a lot of what we're seeing
with agents I find it's helpful to have
a smaller data model if possible um
especially if you're doing different
types of dynamic query generation um so
to keep that in mind but as things are
getting better we can pull back the
graph schema and and offer it to agents
and I'm we're noticing that as agents
sort of keep iter or as language models
really keep iterating they're starting
to get better and better at interpreting
so whenever you want to do traversals in
a low latency a between two data points.
Those things really should go in the
same graph and then it's a question as
far as what you make a label versus a
property um in that scenario. So we'll
go through some of it and then if you
want to talk after and come by our booth
we can have a more sort of use case
focused conversation. Anything else?
All righty. So I'm going to go ahead
here and then dive into the notebook.
So for our first notebook
can go ahead and restart. That's fine.
All righty.
So you're just going to come down here
and start. Um and remember we're in the
uh talent subfolder. So there's two
workshops in here. The one we'll be
doing is called talent. Um, if you're in
the other one, it's there's also some
interesting stuff in there, but you
won't be able to follow along.
Alrighty. So, it looks like I'm running
now. So, basically what I'm going to do
is I'm going to get my environments file
here, and I'm just going to load it. If
you um don't have the environments file,
just go ahead and move it. It's in the
root directory. Just go ahead and move
it into this subdirectory. It's this
WS.N file.
Um, and basically what we're going to do
first is we're just going to load our
skills data sets. It's going to be a
table.
And if we look at that table, um we're
going to have uh basically three fields.
There's the
um an email field, a name field, and
then just a list of skills for the
person. And as I said before, we'll go
into a little bit of detail here around
how you might extract this from
documents like resumeumés um in a
second. Um but basically for now because
we're interested in sort of this skills
uh mapping and team formation and
staffing kind of use case, we're
starting with this sort of very simple
data set to get us started.
Um, and so there's a couple steps here
that just go through basically
organizing the data to make it easy to
load. And then we're going to start to
create our graph. And so a lot of this
is just what we'd call like basic kind
of NeoRaj data loading. We're going to
create chunks out of our data frame.
You're going to um basically check to
make sure you've got nothing in your
database. I do have stuff in my database
because I was just running this before.
Um, but that's on me because I was just
running the course before. Yours should
say zero. Now, the first thing we do is
set a constraint. So, basically inside
of Neo forj, whenever you create nodes,
um, if you have what's called a node key
constraint or a uniqueness constraint,
it's basically saying in this case that
the email has to be unique and nonnull
for all your um, for all your people.
and that will make it so that it's very
fast to match on people and do merging
operations. So, a lot of times people
will say, well, Neo Forj is really slow.
Um, and that's often because of simple
mistakes like not setting a constraint
and then you're going to have to do very
complex searches in the database every
time you search on a user rather than
having it um in an index that's unique.
Um, and then you also do the same for
skill because our data model is going to
be person and skill. So, we have two
types of nodes.
Um, and when we do that, we'll go ahead
and have two constraints here inside of
the database. You'll see for skill and
for person. Um, after that, we'll go
ahead and start loading our nodes um,
and our relationships. So, the way that
this query works, and I I guess I won't
run it, even though it won't actually
change anything in my database, but what
we're doing here is we're looping
through chunks of our data frame, and
we're saying, hey, merge a person on
email, set their name, and then for that
list of skills, basically, you're going
to merge a skill on a skill name, and
then you're going to merge here that the
person knows that skill. So, it's going
to create this graph pattern of person
nose skill in the database.
Once you run that, what you can do is if
you have that browser window open that
we were going over before is I can go
ahead and copy one of these or maybe
I'll just take I'll take this one. Well,
I'll go ahead and take this one first.
What this will show you inside of the
database
is if I just match people. I'll get my
people back here. And I may have lost
Oh, cool. I still have my internet
connection. All right. So, I can go
ahead and see that I have my people.
They have their names and their email
addresses.
Um, you can do the same thing for
matching skills.
And then, um, you can also look for
relationships. So this gets into that
pattern matching that we were talking
about before with cipher. This is a very
simple version of matching a path. So
I'm saying P which is path is equal to
node connect to nodes connects to
another node. And I'm saying limit 25.
And that will return a graph where I get
to see all these different
relationships.
Looks like my internet connection is
still somewhat slow, but I get it back
here. So you'll see I'll get my people.
I'll get that nose relationship. And
then in this case, this person knows API
design, Tableau, Flask. Um, and you'll
see different skills pop up here inside
of your graph.
Um, and there's, you know, you can you
can go ahead and run these through what
through our driver here as well to look
at the data, um, pull back the different
people that are in there, um, and find
out what skills they have and such. We
do here.
Yeah.
Nose is a relationship type. We are
making it up. So our our domain model
that we have um I can actually call it
here and mine is going to show more than
yours if you run the same command
because it has the um some other later
stuff that we do in the course. But
basically you have person knows skill.
That's our data model. So you can say
person has skill would be another way to
put it right. Um the word is just
something that exactly there's an edge
there. Exactly. Yeah. And it's it's
actually funny because this is becoming
even more important um now that we're
using uh LLMs to design queries because
like the language that you use is sort
of like an annotation for the model,
right? So that starts to become very
interesting.
All righty. So there's some cipher
queries here that I'll go ahead and run
through really quick. And I may uh
depending on time need to need to kind
of speed things up through this notebook
because I want to make sure that we
actually get to the agent at the end. Um
so um if you go into the uh the deck
there's this link browser.ne.iopreview
and then I think it's just your username
and your password. Um but you can also
look inside of your um workshop
environment file and it will have that
information there. You just use your
username and your password and your URI
information. Um what you get here. So
you get your URI and then your username
and your password.
All righty. So like I said we'll go
through some of these. So for example we
can count in cipher. So we can say match
person no skill. we can get back the
name and we can count the distinct
people uh basically here for for each
skill. So basically what we're doing
here is you can think of it as like okay
I've got all my skills and I'm going to
count the distinct people that know that
skill. It's very simply what we're
doing. When we get that back we'll see
kind of what our most popular skills are
here. Um going down and they're all kind
of tech focused.
We can also ask different types of
multihop questions which is very
interesting. So, for example, I'll take
this and I'll copy it over to my browser
because it's it's interesting to see
these visually. Um, but what we're
asking here
is we're going to we're going to take
this person um named Lucy and I'm just
going to ask, you know, what people are
kind of similar to Lucy in terms of
knowing the same skills, right?
So, I can go ahead and run that. And
then what I'll get is I'll get Lucy
here. I'll get all of her skills and
then I'll get all the other people that
know those skills here, right? Um, and
you can build on that iteratively. So, I
can if I go back here, I can also say,
well, now I want to know all of those
skills or all of those people and I want
to know basically
I'm going to add at the end of that
query. Um, I get they know a certain
skill and then I want to get all of
those people and then I want to get all
the skills they know. So I'm basically
adding this and what skills do these
other people know to the query and then
I'll get a very large graph back. But
the idea with this is that once we have
this logic extracted from whatever our
original data source is, we can now
control at a much more fine-tuned level
how we define what a similar person is
or what a similar skill is because we
have this ability to traverse over the
graph um and apply um concrete logic.
It's basically like having your
information in a symbolic versus just a
sub symbolic vector. Um, and so, you
know, you'll get a lot of stuff back
because now we're looking at people and
all the other skills that they know. And
I can go in here and find the most
central skills among these people,
right? Like, for example, scrum is very
central among this group. Um, because
there's there's a lot of people that
know that skill. So, I'm figuring out
about this local community that sort of
uh knows similar skills to Lucy.
Um and and in here it's just some
examples of running that uh same logic
um basically inside of the inside of the
notebook. Yes.
forj browser link. I'm over there. I'm
over there. I mean,
oh, I see. Um
you table then graph and then sometimes
if you're not returning nodes, it will
only return a table. Like if I said, you
know, return um
yeah. Okay.
Okay. Yeah. So if you if you just say
return p um in that case it should
return it should return the pass.
Sometimes if you don't see it it's
because you're returning like just a
name or something. Um and then in that
case it'll like just show you a list of
names.
Follow question. What is a distinct
doing in this case? Um
and I don't have a distinct here. Oh
yeah I did. Um
I don't know if it's completely
necessary for this one actually. Um
yeah, I don't think it is completely
necessary for this one. Um there are
times when you do very complicated
especially we'll see that there are a
couple other examples where we do like
multihop paths and there's a chance with
some of those that you'll get basically
two paths that are the same. um in which
case having the distinct there just
allows you to um filter it better.
Yep.
So that's hard to say. They're getting
better. Um a lot of it depends on the
complexity of your schema. Um and
basically you know we see for simpler
aggregation queries or when you have a
lot of prompt engineering around doing
different types of path queries that are
very specific on a smaller model they
can do well. Um we do often recommend
that you have your own expert tools if
there's like a really complicated type
of traversal that you want to do. So
right you can write your own Python
functions or you can have your own MCP
server that will just have like your you
know set of functions for your more
complicated traversals. Uh we also see
too you can sort of restrict the options
for LLM. So instead of writing a
complete query you can say hey like
there's you know these you know three
types of general patterns you know and
and write that part of the pattern and
then it will go into this other query.
So you can do stuff like that to help
it. Um we've also done we've had
fine-tuned models that we just released
um I think back in April. Um they're on
they're fine-tuned from GMA. They're on
hugging face. Um so you can try using
those as well. they can do a little bit
better.
We're not going to use them here though,
unfortunately, because we're using a
bunch of OpenAI uh OpenAI models for
this.
Um, all righty. So, a lot of this, um,
as as I was just going over is basically
just running these queries. Um,
returning in this case, the distinct is
important to return a distinct name
because you might actually get to the
same person multiple times. Um, so if
you're just returning a name and a an um
of a skill, right, then it's important
to um to to use distinct in that case.
So we get all the distinct skills that
basically showed up in the graph we were
just looking at. Um, another thing that
might be important for our use case is
finding similar people. Um, so this is
again using that uh query that we were
just going over to find. We used Lucy
before, but now we can actually uh
parameterize that here. Um and then
basically go no skill and then we can
match um basically from that skill going
to another person and we can sort of
count number of shared skills between
people.
Um and so when we do that right
um we can go ahead and see in this case
um like the number of shared skills
between um between different
individuals.
Um and we do it again here I think for
a different set of people. I think this
just counts most skills shared between
any two people. Um so you can kind of
see that here. Again, just another way
to measure similarity beyond just
semantic similarity, measuring actually
um what we have from our model in terms
of exact shared skills.
Um and as we go through this, some of
the things that we can do to help speed
up our queries, and this is this is sort
of optional, but if we know that we're
going to um sort of look for similar
skill sets a lot, we can create a
similar skill relationship inside of our
graph. Um so basically we can match two
different people um and then we can
merge uh a similar skill set basically
be based on um an overlap of the um of a
skill count. So we have our data frame
locally that we can use for that that we
that we were just looking we basically
just pulled it back when we were looking
at those similar skills. And what that's
going to do is it's just going to create
again this uh relationship that has
similar skill set between people. Um,
and if I were to look at that, it will,
um,
go over to my browser.
We'll go ahead and see,
you know, I can have a similar skill.
Some of these are overlap one, others
will be greater. Um, inside of here, I
think they go up to three. Um so it's
all this is doing is basically saying
hey if two people like what is their
overlap so we don't have to do that full
traversal over and over again if we
don't want to um with that similar skill
set relationship.
Um the next thing I wanted to show you
and yes but if you do this you need to
like this is static and if you want to
update what's the overlap you need to
run this query again. You would need to
run that query over again. Yeah. So, I
mean, it it depends on how often your
data gets updated. There's nothing
actually wrong with doing the multihop
query over and over again. Um, the graph
database is designed to handle that. So,
if you had a situation where you had a
graph that was um constantly getting
updated, you you might not even need to
create this relationship.
Um, the next thing that I wanted to show
you um was how our graph analytics works
um inside of Neo Forj. and basically
using that to uh enrich the graph. So
this is um basically creating what we
call a GDS or a graph data science
client. Uh and what's going what we're
basically doing here is we're creating
something called a projection and then
we're running a algorithm called Leiden
um for the graphite community. Are you
all have how many people here have heard
of Leiden as an algorithm?
Okay, so just just a few people. How
many people have heard of Louain as a
graph algorithm?
Okay, so we got a couple people.
Basically, what this algorithm does is
it breaks the graph down into a
hierarchy. So, it will start by um
basically breaking the graph into a few
big communities and then going into
smaller communities. And what it's
trying to do is optimize what we call
modularity. And it's basically this
metric that says hey I want to create
these clusters in my graph where the
connections within the cluster are very
high and connections across clusters are
very low. So I'm creating these modules
and basically what I do by creating
these um and I'm using that similar
skill set relationship. So this is
another important reason to create it
because if you do um analytics on your
graph um it can help with those
analytics running a little bit better
because I have person connects to
another person with a similar skill set.
Um and by running this lid in algorithm
basically what we get is uh a bunch of
communities that reflect people within
the communities knowing similar skills.
Um, so this is all simulated data,
but basically if I go down to um, and
I'll skip over some of this. We do some
checks around like how good the
communities are. I encourage you to run
this just so that the agent works well
at the end. Um, but the what I wanted to
show you here is this uh, graphic right
here. So what this is this graphic is
looking at because basically we wrote
this community ID property back to the
graph and you get these different
community ids and you get to see which
communities in a heat map have the most
skills in a certain in a certain area.
So this data is randomly generated. So a
lot of these patterns are going to look
maybe a little bit funky if you were to
really dig into them. But the idea is
that um as you have very if as you have
more relevant data and realistic data
this can actually show you like your
data engineers are here right and your
front-end guys and front-end folks are
over here and then your ML people are
over here so you can start to see that
within the graph um and really break
that down. Um but do go ahead and run
everything here um through the g. So
that you have that property. Uh another
way that we can break down
uh sort of different groups inside of
the graph is to look at Go ahead. Sorry.
I just had one question regarding when
do you customize your community that
you're running? Yeah.
actually better to figuring out
well I think it depends on your use case
right like if you're very interested in
you know saying hey I want to understand
like the skill communities inside of my
company right if that's like a question
that's going to come up frequently then
using something like graph analytics can
be very beneficial, right? Because you
can do basically like employee
segmentation and you can understand
performance with inside of different
groups and stuff. We see it oftent times
used for customer segmentation and
recommendation systems and that sort of
thing too. Um at the same time, if
you're just like, hey, I just want to
like look for matches of different
people with similar skills, maybe you
don't need community detection for that
because that's just like a pairing
exercise, right? Um, so I'd say you use
it whenever you want to do some sort of
clustering analysis and persist that and
then sort of even have visibility and I
guess the the confidence in knowing that
there was some way that you did that,
right? And it's not just up to the model
that's just making stuff up around how
that works, right? So basically you look
at what the users are doing and then
trying to see
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Yes.
Secondary skills. The heat map is
showing you how often different skills
show up with inside of each community.
Yeah. So like the first community for
example is it looks like either Tableau
or Swift right?
Yeah. To understand like the skill
breakdown within each community. And
again this is generated data. So, this
is a little bit random, right? Um, but
you can imagine that in a non-random
scenario, what you're probably going to
end up seeing is like if you have a lot
of product managers versus a lot of, you
know, um, like front-end developers
versus, you know, like DevOps folks,
like you'll see that grouping start to
emerge.
Yes. Two connected questions. One, do
you have any different best practices
for data modeling for an agent to
understand the data model or general
graph best practices around creating
data models. Um yeah, I mean I'd say a
lot of the agent stuff is evolving super
super quickly. Um you know as LLMs keep
changing and getting better. Um we've
had for a long time guides on how to do
like data migration from relational
systems to graph and how to think about
that. There's a certain way in graph how
you think about again like nodes being
nouns, relationships being verbs and how
to connect those together. For agents, I
think it's really nice when the data
model reflects a natural language,
right? So, person knows skill. It's very
natural language way of, you know,
saying something that that translates
directly to a data model. And as I was
saying before, simpler data models seem
to work better when you do like dynamic
query generation. Um, so there's stuff
like that. And the rest of it is I know
like the it depends answer is like you
know such a copout but it is true that
like depending on the type of retrievers
that you have the size of your data um
the cardality of different categories of
things in your data right like you know
you generally don't want if you can
avoid it to have hundreds or thousands
of node labels because it's just a lot.
So then you make them properties. So
there's a lot of stuff like that to
consider. So I don't know if that
answers your question. Um the first part
is how you have seen it be effective to
show the
reason
what sort of schema file would you give
it or what
yeah we'll see at the end of module
three which we might not have time to
get to but you'll see it in the code and
I'll I'll show it really quick is that
there's you can from the graph schema
there's um functions that we have to
pull back the node labels and the
relationship ship types. So you can
create a sort of JSON representation,
right, of what the graph schema looks
like um and then combine it with
specific prompts. So then it's like
okay, I follow that. Another um thing to
do that helps even more is if you have a
graph data model that's not going to
change a lot over time where you know
you can just pull it and it will be the
same for a while is you can annotate
that schema. So you can say like for
specific properties or node labels or
relationship types hey this thing does
this and when you ingest data make sure
you you know put it here and when you
pull data make sure you can you know go
on different paths. The other thing is
putting in like we had person nose
skill. Putting those actual query
patterns into the schema as well helps a
lot because the model can read that and
then understand how to do that traversal
better.
All right. Anything else?
Right. Cool. Um so we're actually
getting close on time. So I'm going to
go pretty quickly through the rest of
this. Um but hopefully um
it'll be pretty understandable. So
there's another way that we can start um
thinking about skills and relationships
between skills is how they're
semantically similar. Um so basically
what we can do is actually make
embeddings on our skills. So there's
another file in here um that basically
has a CSV file that you read into this
notebook that has skills and
descriptions and an embedding. So which
which field here do you think we
embedded the skills or the description
and why right so one of the things is
when you have really short names like R
is a technically a programming language
although a lot of people don't love it I
love R um AWS like they're very short
right so having descriptions about those
uh skill names if you embed those it
provides a more informative embedding
heading, right? So, that's the whole
idea there. So, basically, we give each
skill a description and then we embed
that description. And what we're seeing
inside of this is we're actually going
to um and these are all text embedding
ADA, so they're so they're 1536. Um
we're going to go ahead and create a
vector property. Um this is just loading
those up in chunks. Um and then we're
going to set the description as well.
And after we do that, um, we'll
basically have I think we create our
vector index down here that we call the
skills embedding.
Once that's set up, basically what we're
able to do, and you'll see it show up
here. We'll get that skills embedding
index, is we're now going to be able to
do vector search on skills inside of the
graph. So, if I have Python as a skill
and I go ahead and I'll use this command
in Cipher to search the skills
embedding, pull back the 10 most
relevant skills. Um, and you'll see here
it'll it'll bring some skills back. Um,
here it's like Ruby and Java. We got
pandas at least that's good. Django,
PyTorch. Um, so some of these are better
than others, but the point is that we
can go ahead and apply these vectors um
and then pull information back with
vector search.
And another interesting thing that we
can do um as well
is we can if I had something that wasn't
in the database like say I'm just
looking for API coding right and I
searched that as a term basically what
I'm doing here is I'm using the open AI
uh client here to just embed this model
or I might be using actually lang chain
up here looks like it's lang chain um
and then I'm doing a search on the
database to pull back relevant skills
with a certain similarity threshold and
I'll get back API design and JavaScript
for that API coding example.
Um, and what I can actually do in this
case is I can say well I have this
ability to do semantic similarity in the
database. I can actually write a
relationship that's just similar
semantic and I can attach a score to
that. Um, so there's some advantages to
doing this, but a big one is
visualization and also clustering. So if
I were to take this command, which takes
a semant similar semantic relationship
and I go into my graph
and I just put that in here and I just
return all basically the skills that are
semantically similar.
This internet speeds up hopefully.
and I zoom in, I'll start to see sort of
interesting groupings here. So,
I'll start to see for example that I get
my cloud skills here, Azure, AWS, cloud
architecture all in one place.
Similarly, like I have Flask and Django
here connected. I've got my data
analytics group. This is like Tableau,
PowerBI, data visualization. Um, and
then I've got a big grouping over here.
So you see like you have your JVM
languages like your Java and Scola and
Cotlin here. Um and then I've got you
know my Python stuff here with pandas.
And then if I go up in this group that's
connected right I've got my Java and
then I've got like all this front-end
you know frameworks and stuff up here.
Um so
don't underestimate the power of being
able to visualize similarities.
Very important because I can create
communities from these. I can use this
for customized scoring in my retrieval
queries which we'll see. Um, but the
other really cool thing is that um, if
for some reason like maybe I don't think
Java should be connected to Python, I
can control that. I can remove that
relationship and then every time I do
similarity relationships, I have control
over that and I can filter that, right?
Um, so that's just some important things
to keep in mind about how you can um,
sort of use vectors and graphs together.
Quick question. Is it only when you do
semantic similarity? Is it only to
visualize or any other? We'll see in a
bit here because basically what what we
can do and I'll answer this actually as
I as I go down. Um I can pull back this
semantic similarity relationship here.
But what I can start to do um which is
actually pretty cool is I can start
creating these
um sort of customized scorings between
things that kind of balance the like the
semantic similarity versus hard rel like
skill matches and I can weight that if I
wanted to in in a custom way. So you can
use it in your retrieval patterns as
well to improve things.
Um
pattern would you go directly or would
you vector search
again? Do you use both typically or you
so you can use both. Um so there's a lot
of workflows because now you can compose
things together into multi multiple
steps, right? So you can definitely do
something where you can pull similar
skills and then look for people, right?
And it just depends on how you break
down those functions for the agents.
Sometimes if you know that like there's
a very specific pattern that you want to
follow. Like here, this is a very this
looks like a really big query. It's
somewhat intimidating, but it's actually
not that complicated. Like what you're
doing here is you're just sort of doing
a waiting between the semantic
similarity and a hard like overlap with
similar skill sets. Like that might be a
case where it actually coupling that
logic together might make sense. Like if
there's a very specific type of metric
that you want for similarity.
What if you're coming from when you're
coming from you have a
much largerology
like tell me about people with certain
skills. How do you know that these are
looking at what's the first step when
you go from
to retrieval? How do you break it into
the entities to know that this is the
second or this is the you should be
doing? Does that make sense? Yeah. I
mean, why don't we revisit that when we
get to the third module? The second
module should be really quick and then
we can you can see some of the functions
in the third module and then that might
help me answer that question a little
bit better. I think I know where you're
going, but maybe seeing that will help.
Um, so as I said before, this is doing
kind of like a a balance between the
semantic similarity and sort of a a hard
overlap of skills. And then you can use
that to kind of weight, you know, how
you want to find similar people inside
of the graph. Um, so you can you can
start balancing both sort of the vector
search similarity and the uh similarity
that uh just happens with inside of the
hard matches. And another cool thing
about a graph database specifically is
I'll go ahead and take this query here.
Um, just so you can see what this looks
like. Oh, go ahead.
Yeah, I mean you could go either way,
right? So some of a lot of this to be
honest will come down to cost
considerations like how expensive is it
in Neo forj versus how expensive is it
inside of Postgress and that varies a
lot depending on the type of
infrastructure you have. Having
everything in one place means that you
it's a little bit you don't have to like
sync your data right and then you also
the query latency is at least in theory
going to be lower because you're just
querying from the same database. Um but
if you already have data in Postgress
maybe or you already have a specialized
vector database you also don't have to
migrate your data necessarily to Neo
forj to make that work. So yeah I'd say
a lot of it actually it's performance
but it's really like cost per
performance right is kind of what you're
thinking about in terms of what what
does each deployment cost.
Um so this query here um is actually I'm
taking I'm looking for similarity
between two people and then you see I
have this like star dot dot thing here
and basically with a graph you're
allowed to do what's called variable
length queries. So I'm saying hey go out
on similar semantic but you're allowed
to go out anywhere from zero to two hops
between these skill sets before you find
a connection between John and Matthew um
here. And then I can also union it
against just the plain you know person
knows same skill. Um and when we get
that back we'll see right like you get
Matthew over here Matthew knows React
John knows HTML and then those are sort
of similar because they both have a
semantic similarity to JavaScript. Same
thing here you see we have this uh
semantic similarity but this is only one
hop. This is where the variable hop
comes in. So you can start to control
like these, you know, sort of how far
out you can go on on either of these
paths to be able to pull back
similarities between people.
Um, this is just an advantage of a graph
database.
Then I think might want to finish it off
for this notebook. Um, I would take a
break except that uh we only have 23
more minutes.
So what do you say? Should we just power
through the last 20 minutes? You think?
Yeah, let's let's let's do that. So now
I will we looked at some of the
advantages of using the graph and the
semantic similarity inside of the graph.
And now we'll talk a little bit about
our second module here. And I won't go
over to the slides because I think for
you guys I can probably just hop right
into the notebook around well what if we
have just résumés, right? We don't have
a CSV file. So this is going to be a
simple example that will show you um
basically how to take the data um from
text and turn it into useful data for
the graph. So again like if you're if
you're going through and running this
live you're just connecting to your same
workshop file which you should have from
before testing the connection making
sure you can count now you should
actually get 154 nodes. So here, and if
you come by our booth, we can show you
much more uh sort of exciting examples
than than the two text uh blobs that we
have here. Um but here we have two
different bios. Um and basically the way
that you can do this, and if you've
already done some entity extraction,
you're probably already familiar with
this workflow,
is we can define our domain model um in
terms of uh pyantic classes. Uh so here
basically I'm going to define my person
with a name and an email and then a list
of skills. Um and then I have the skills
field here. Um if you add relationship
properties you would have like a nose
maybe like in a more complicated model.
nose as a relationship would also have
like a proficiency property in which
case this would be a list of you know
nose skills and then you would have a
nose skill would have a class um would
have a skill property inside of it but
you can see this is a very simple
example. So all we're doing here is
we're defining a list of skills that
someone can have. skills just has the
name property and then we can create
this person list and then once we have
our uh pideantic uh class defined uh we
can create our system message uh to
basically be a prompt for our model um
and then we can use in this case I used
uh 41 here um and we gave it the
documents to uh to ingest and then it
will spit out at the end of this some
JSON uh with those two people. So, we
had two documents. Each one um
corresponded to one person. And then we
got our emails and skills um with all
their different names and such. Um and
once we have that right, um it's it's
from there it's pretty trivial to load
it in. It's very similar to what we did
last time. Um in fact if we go down to
our graph creation here we'll see uh
this isn't exactly the query that we had
but uh it's very similar where we've
basically we're ingesting one person at
a time merging on that uh email address
which we have indexed sending the name
and then for each of the skills that's
sort of a list inside of there um we're
going to go ahead and merge uh the skill
name and then that nose property
connecting them together.
Um, and then of course I could go back
to the graph and I can say um, these are
Neo Forj employees that I loaded. Um,
but I can go ahead and look for one of
them in the graph and I should get them
back here. Um, where I have them and I
have the different skills uh, that they
went ahead and uh, picked up um, that I
can put inside of the database. So um,
very very simple. Uh we have um our own
um graph rag Python package as well
which is very good for and and also our
knowledge graph builder. If you look at
some of the code that we used um to
implement that which is kind of like a
reference UI um which has more sort of
examples around if you wanted to do
things like document chunking with
overlap um you know and and of course
also doing like multi-threading with
async and stuff like that. So you're not
just, you know, doing a for loop, you
know, over over a bunch of over a bunch
of BIOS. So we have all of that. If you
stop by the booth, we'll we can we can
give you more around that. Um but like I
said, especially for this crowd because
you guys are already familiar with this.
Um you know, this is this is a very
short module and yes, so we just gone
through two, added them to the graph. We
now need to go our data.
So So we would have to do that. Yeah.
So, ideally I would have done this in in
an order where I would have done this
first and then we've we've got we would
have gone through like the clustering
materializing new relationship with
them. We're we're putting new
relationships in these don't have
weights on them but if we wanted to
reformulate our communities um you go
then everyone can hear. Thank you. So so
the the communities
I'm kind of following what you're doing.
you're adding extra links in between the
nodes that have weights on them. Whether
it's for semantic distance for skills or
whether it's for you know you you are X
hops away from somebody else in terms of
some other distance computation that
you've materialized.
Yeah. So we would we would ideally we
run that in a recurring way as we upload
data. Right. So because I created I did
in this case create I think some new
skills in addition to the people. So
like has same has similar skill set that
we would we would redo that and then we
would get a couple more relationships
there. Um the semantic one if we created
new skills we would create new semantic
relationships between the skills. Yes.
Okay. Thank you.
All right. Any other questions
before we move on? I'm ready. All right.
Well, then that was a uh a very quick
module. So, I'll go over and cover um
just some other topics around this very
very quickly
um inside of my inside of my slides
here.
Um, so what we saw was an example where
I'd call it entity extraction or named
entity recognition where we were taking
a document and we were literally
breaking out people, places, and things
and relationships from within that
document. Um, there's other things that
we can do like for example, if we have
certain types of documents like from a
catalog or in this case RFPs,
um, we can start to break things out by
actual document structure. So I'm only
going to walk through this just so you
understand that there's different types
of extraction that we can do to create
graphs. Um for example, if you know what
the anatomy of a document is, like in
this case, if we have an RFP, um we know
that this RFP is going to be designed in
a way where there'll be different
sections that we have an intro,
objective, proposal, and subsections
within that. We can actually create a
graph out of those things too. So this
is another way that we can do um I would
call it more like document extraction
where we're actually putting the the
metadata of the document and modeling it
as a graph. Uh and the advantage of
doing things this way is that basically
as you start to embed these different
pieces
um and put them into a knowledge graph.
Um you can basically do these patterns
where you can do these searches on
either entities that come from different
chunks. Um and you can sort of go up and
down uh these uh document hierarchies to
find things which can be very helpful if
you have documents that always have
repeated structure. Um so you know that
entity sometime connects between those
the structures of those documents. You
can start to incorporate that inside of
your um graph retrieval queries. Um, and
then it also gives you a way to do
community summaries because we saw
Leiden before. Um, but also if you have
documents that give you a natural uh
hierarchy, um, you have a way of also
summarizing information um, across those
documents as well. Yeah. Why do you have
entities and documents and chunks in the
sameology as opposed to extracting
entities
and just separate separate documents?
Why do you combine the two? Well, I
think when they're combined, you you can
just do traversals between them. So,
what do you what's
traversal you want to do?
an example that you want to do between a
traversal of entities and trunks. Like I
say like legal contracts is a good
example where if you know like you want
to search for different legal clauses
but then like the expiry date that might
be somewhere else. So like that would be
one example. Yeah.
Yes. So just making sure I understand.
So like
just want to make sure I'm uh clear on
what you're talking about traversing the
document. So in a legal document say
like a data protection clause across
multiple vendors or something like that
and comparing the language like is that
a use case? Yeah. Yeah. Okay. Yeah. So
that and then like you know so there
might be like um like a perpetuity piece
or like you know dates and different
things and then being able to kind of
traverse over that document to find that
in addition to the entities.
Anything
else?
All right.
All righty. So, I just wanted to
introduce that as as another example of
how to do things um for the third module
because we're already at 1007. So, let
me just go ahead and jump into the
thing. So, you'll get to see it.
We'll go over to module three. And this
is going to be very simple. So, has has
that who here we probably asked this in
the beginning. I think we already asked
how many people have experience building
agents. This is going to be very simple.
It's just going to be a langraph agent
that we're going to that we're going to
make here. Um, basically what we're
going to do is again a similar setup
with our environments file. We're going
to connect to Neo Forj, test our
connection.
Um, there's going to be four tools that
we want to build. We want to be able to
retrieve the skills of a person. We want
to be able to retrieve similar skills to
other skills, similar people, like if we
wanted to find out who's another good
person to work on a thing. Um, and then
retrieve people based on a set of
skills.
And in this example,
um, we're basically going to, um, do a
lot of tools first. So, at the end of
this notebook, there's going to be like
that text to cipher stuff where you get
the schema back. But here, what we're
going to go over first is actually going
to be putting these different tools
together. Um, and we do that by graph
patterns. And it's the same graph
patterns that we've been going over. Uh,
so for example here, right, if we just
want to find um the skills that someone
knows, it's very simple, right? Just
person matching to their skills. Um, and
as you go down this notebook, basically
what you're seeing is all the different
patterns. So the second is retrieving
people with similar skills. And here
we're actually going to use the um the
vector index and that similar semantic
relationship. Um so we're basically
going to pull um actually this one is
searching for people with skills. I
apologize. So in this one the this is um
you're going to look for skills. So for
example you if a user puts in different
skills those might not match the skills
we have inside of the database exactly
word for word. So you're going to use
vector search to pull out um the
specific skills and what's semantically
similar to those skills and we can do
some scoring thresholds in here to pull
back exactly what we want. Um and then
that will go ahead and return some
skills. So if we had for example right
like this continuous delivery cloud
native and security
um this would be like the types of
skills that we pull back from that.
the person's similarity. Um, there's a
few different ways that we can do that
and we've talked about that a lot
towards the beginning. Um, we can do it
by community. So, we can look for people
that know different skills. We can get
all of their names and then we can look
for um that lighten community that we
created. We can look for all the skills
that those people know. And basically
what we're doing at that point is we're
looking for people inside of the same uh
skills uh community.
Um but the other way that you can do
that is um you can look for similar
skill sets um using the uh similar skill
set relationship. So the hardcoded
relationship that we've made from before
uh which basically looks at hey how many
how what's the actual skill overlap if
you just looked at um who knows what
inside of the graph. Um and that will
bring back um some answers here between
so we were looking at John Garcia and
we're saying hey find similar people and
then we can get like a score count of
overlap um to the to the different
people here. Um and then we can start
adding in that semantic similarity. So
this is where we get this big query
right but what this query is actually
doing is it's sort of balancing between
the um similar skill set and
semantically similar skill set. So, it's
kind of taking both those scores and
adding them together. Um, and then from
there, we get uh a floating number score
um and a little bit of a different
answer that's not just based on hard
skill connections, but also skills that
are kind of close together. Um, and we
can weight those independently as well.
Um, and we can also recommend people
given a set of skills. So if we have a
set of skills here um we can just do a
vector search on um on those skills. Um
and then actually this one
combination of person skills skills.
Yeah, here it is. Um
so basically um the query was broken out
into two parts just because this is this
is kind of a big thing to look at but
the idea with this is we can get um we
can basically do vector search on skills
get semantically similar skills um and
then find person who knows those skills.
So very similar to some of the last ones
um and then we can get a skill count for
all of those groups and get people back.
Um when we actually define the functions
for our agent um we're going to create
here um a skills object which basically
is just going to help us um with some of
our function arguments and returns u but
basically first tool retrieve skills of
person very simple query
um and then we'll have uh down here for
tool for tool two when we say find
similar skills um what we're going to
look at here is again that query where
we're going to do that semantic
similarity between skills. So we're
going to do a vector search to find
skills and then we're going to go out
one hop on semantic similarity. Um and
then we're basically going to collect
everything and return it.
And then for the third one we're going
to do that waiting um because this tool
three is going to be for person
similarity. We're going to do that
waiting between the similar semantic and
the similar skill set with that larger
query.
And then I know I'm going through this
kind of quickly. For the fourth one
where we say find person based on skills
here again our entry point is going to
be a vector search on skills. Um going
out to match those semantically similar
skills but then kind of at the end of
that uh we'll add on a traversal that
will attach the person to knowing those
skills count who knows the most and then
effectively return that. So those are
the four tools that we're going to end
up using for this agent. Um when we set
up the agent here, if you're familiar
with uh how Langraph works,
basically uh we we get our LLM, we test
that it's alive, we define our list of
tools. We can if we didn't want to do
this in an agentic way, right? We can
just bind our tools to our LLM. Um and
we can we can invoke our LLM with tools.
Um, but what we're going to do instead,
this is just showing invoking the
different the different tools, um, is we
are going to go and run it with an
agent. So, we're going to use create
react agent, which comes from Langraph.
Um, it's one of their pre-built agent,
um, that uses the the React um, I don't
know if you'd call it a framework, but
um, sort of that methodology uh, to
build an agent.
And effectively um once we do that, we
give it the LLM, we give it the four
tools, uh that we had and then um we can
see that here we're just testing. We're
saying hi and we're just making sure we
get some response back. There's a
utility function here just to make it
easier running in the notebook um which
will basically just you know do this
some of the um some of the streaming
methodology. So, I can just say, "Hey,
what skills um does Kristoff have?" And
then if I run that, and I don't know if
I need to rerun my agent here. Looks
like not. Everything's running. Um,
so you'll see it says, uh, when I ran
that, and actually I ran it for the
wrong question
here. What skills does Kristoff have?
Person named Kristoff. And then it will
bring back his skills. So you see there
it will choose to use the uh retrieve
skills of person. Um and similarly if I
went down and I said you know what
skills are similar to PowerBI and data
visualization
um it'll go through and choose the
appropriate um
you know the the appropriate tool for
the job. So in this case, uh, find
similar skills. It'll pull those back
and you'll see going down, right? If I
said, well, what person has similar
skills to, you know, this other person
here, um, then it will know, oh, I need
person similarity. So we'll go ahead and
use that specific tool. So in this case,
what we're doing is we're providing a
bunch of tools that are presumably
expert tools that we can give to the
model and then it will know that okay, I
have to go ahead and pull those um those
specific tools to be able to uh provide
a response.
And then there's a little app down here
as well if you wanted to run the uh
chatbot. So
um it's a little grad app here.
Um but basically if I ran that I can go
ahead and come in here and then I can
have a little conversation with it. So
this is very small but what skills are
similar you know I can go ahead and ask
it in here and then provided
everything's working it'll go ahead and
choose the appropriate tool and then I
can say well who knows um you know um
maybe I'll just say those skills and it
should
um go ahead and pull the appropriate
tool to be able to find out who knows
all these different skills, right? And
if I go back to my uh to my example
here, I should see the query logic that
it used. So, first, you know, it said
find similar skills to what I just
mentioned because I asked about PowerBI.
And then after that, I asked about uh
people who know skills. So, it said find
persons based on similar skills. And
likewise I can say you know who is um
similar to those people
in the graph
and it will likewise go through and it
should you know understand that it needs
to use the find other similar persons
tools um to be able to do that.
So you'll see if I if I was to keep
going down
I should get calls um here define
persons with similar we have it here.
Yeah person similarity. So it just
called the person similarity for each
person.
Um and I know we only have a few minutes
left. Uh there is if you wanted to run
this further basically um I have a text
to cipher example. So this is where I'll
have an example of passing it the
annotated schema. So this is getting to
kind of what you were asking about,
right? Um where I've provided these
descriptions. Um so it's sort of like
annotations for the schema as well. And
then I can go ahead and give that to an
aggregation query function that will
have there's also an LLM inside of here
that will create the cipher. Um but you
can see in here I asked it some
questions like describe communities. it
was able to understand that it needed to
grab, you know, the the match person
knows skill and then it needed to grab
the lighting community. So, it it knew
from the schema, right, that it needed
to generate this cipher. Um, and there's
a couple more examples of that in the
notebook. Um, are there any question? I
know I just went over a lot. Um, are
there any questions from that that are
worth answering now while we have just a
couple minutes left?
I didn't even know you were here. How
long will the uh Jupyter server be up if
we want to play with this? Jupiter
server is going to go down very quickly,
but if you look at the deck at the end
of the deck, I have a link to the code
and the data is all in GitHub too. So
basically
if if you go here, that's the GitHub
repository. So you can play with it. I
get the deck. What's that? The the deck
is in this. Do you have access to the
Slack channel? Yes. So, the deck is in
the Slack channel. Um, and I I'll go
ahead and and jump to that in a second,
but there's the GitHub repository. You
can use Aura um console. We have a free
trial that you can use. You can just set
up a cloud database and you can load the
data into there. Um, also before you
guys leave, there's a meetup happening
tomorrow. Um, it's tonight.
Oh, sorry. tonight at five. Um that and
there's a link there for more
information on that. Um and then we also
have another workshop at uh one o'clock
where today was very simple like we're
going to go over more graph analytics
type of stuff in that workshop. So like
the community stuff that I was doing,
we're going to dive more into depth on
that in that workshop. Um other than
that, uh come by our booth if you have
more questions. We're going to be
wherever right there is. I don't think
we have a big expo hall, but if you want
to see Neo forj MCP servers, ADK
examples, more knowledge graph
construction, um all a great uh you know
place to come to ask all those types of
questions.
[Music]